mma fighter and woman beater alana
mclaughlin now the most important thing
to know about mclaughlin is that he is a
male and when i say he's a male i mean
he has xy chromosomes and a male
reproductive system and male gametes so
makes a person a male he also has a male
bone structure muscle structure he's
male from head to toe from skin to bone
from his brain down to his cells down to
his dna literally every part of him is
male if they dig up his remains 100
years from now no matter how much of him
is left they will be able to tell that
he was male that will indeed be one of
the only things they will be able to
tell about him that's because your
maleness or your femaleness is one of
the most ingrained most permanent most
enduring aspects of who you are it
remains even after you die mclaughlin
will be a male even when he doesn't
exist anymore that's how male he is
think about that and yet that didn't
stop him from fighting a woman in the
mma ring during the combat global
prelims on friday night mclaughlin
fought and easily defeated celine
provost he eventually got her into a
submission hold and choked her out this
was again a man beating the crap out of
a woman